just like all TLS typical liberals
Hunter Biden is now playing the victim
card it always comes down to that now in
a lawsuit he filed against the IRS Biden
is claiming that whistleblowers targeted
and sought to embarrass him
no Hunter I think you did that all by
yourself with the Coke and the
prostitutes now the guy who gets
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
Anonymous buyers for his below art wants
a thousand dollars in Damages for each
and every unauthorized disclosure of his
tax returns joining me now chairman of
the house oversight committee James
Comer Congressman good to see you
tonight now Hunters attorneys are saying
that the whistleblowers do not have the
traditional immunity from civil suit
because of their supposed wrongful
conduct against him your response well
that's simply not true the
whistleblowers have protected
whistleblower protection Democrats in
Congress used to care about that they
used to file bills and pass bills to
protect whistleblowers and encourage
whistleblowers to come forward that's
exactly what the two Brave
whistleblowers did who testified before
my house oversight committee but what
we're seeing now in in real life form is
witness intimidation by the Biden legal
team they want to send a message to any
other potential whistleblowers out there
do not cooperate with the house
oversight committee do not cooperate
with this investigation or we will sue
you and see that you're liable and have
to pay out your entire life savings for
simply telling the truth
Congressman also on a separate note Abby
Lowell one of Hunter Biden's attorneys
is out there claiming that you're being
dishonest in one of your requests
about this February issue of Hunter's
bank records which you claim that they
never responded to but he is saying that
Hunter's legal team did respond the next
day saying uh in part I would offer to
sit with you and your staff to see
whether Mr Biden has information that
may inform some legitimate legislative
purpose and be helpful to the committee
but you never responded to that offer so
what's the real story here Congressman
the real story is we asked for bank
records and he wanted to come in and
offered to patronize and waste taxpayer
dollars by tying up legal fees wondering
why we couldn't understand why we were
requesting him he wanted to know the
legislative intent when everyone in
America knows that the Biden family has
taken in over 20 million dollars from
foreign and they can't say a single
thing they did to earn this money so if
Joe Biden wants to do what he said he
would do when he was running for
president and be the most transparent
president in the history of America he
can comply with our simple request if
he's innocent then he'll make us look
bad but instead of complying with our
request and being transparent with his
personal finances he set up a war room
in the white house he's suing
whistleblowers who have bravely come
forward to tell the truth about how
their credible investigation was
obstructed and they continued to do
everything in their power to obstruct
this investigation
well meanwhile we have uh we have it
looks like Hakeem Jeffries is saying
that there's a civil war Congressman
Brewing over uh the impeachment question
check this out
there are no facts on the record to
suggest that President Biden engaged in
impeachable offenses this is an
illegitimate impeachment inquiry it's a
product of the house Republican Civil
War
Civil War quickly Congressman your
reaction well there's no Civil War we're
having a lot of challenging discussions
about how to fund the government moving
forward but with respect to the
impeachment and query there's
overwhelming support in the House of
Representatives among the Republican
conference to conduct this investigation
we've proven uh mountains of evidence
that this family has broken many laws
and that Joe Biden was front and center
in these schemes and there's also
support in the Senate Jim Jordan and I
spoke to the Senators at their weekly
luncheon last week and a majority of the
senators were excited and encouraging
about our investigation well Mitch
McConnell cares about Ukraine
Congressman good to see you thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else